[Applaudissements]
bien bonjour à tous merci merci de votre
accueil effectivement on va parler de
connexion et on sait que les connexions
intergénérationnel c'est notre pain
quotidien ça fait trente ans que je suis
pédopsychiatre j'ai vu les choses
changent et est donc le monde
le monde de demain va être un monde
hyper connecté hyper connectés mais il
l'est déjà d'ailleurs et les jeunes
adultes et les adolescents de la
génération actuellement sont très
connectés mais vous avez remarqué
houlette ils sont connectés entre eux et
si on pose la question à des jeunes qui
traînaient depuis 2000 sur cette
question là
quel est le lien entre ces deux objets
il ya fort à parier que les plus jeunes
d'entre nous d'entre vous puisse se
poser la question et ne pas répondre
parce que tant que vous n'avez pas
rembobinez votre cassette avec le crayon
il est absolument impossible de
comprendre quel est le lien et bien
finalement si ce code là qui est tout
simple il est pas compris on peut
imaginer que beaucoup d'autres codes
sont totalement incompréhensible pour la
plupart des jeunes et des moins jeunes
donc c'est intéressant de se pencher
aujourd'hui sur les formidables mutation
sociologique qui ont permis de modifier
les comportements des uns et des autres
et peut-être être à l'origine d'un
certain nombre de malentendus malentendu
qui sont à la fois des malentendus
familiaux mais aussi les malentendus
professionnels combien de parents
viennent me voir depuis une dizaine
d'années en disant doc on sait plus qu
on sait plus quoi faire
ils m'amènent leur adolescent il me
laisse en dépôt vente en disant est ce
que vous avez une solution pour lui
parce qu'il est tout le temps connecté
hyper connectés et même au niveau
professionnel
eh bien on a avec nos jeunes
collaborateurs nous mois qui suit la
génération des baby boomers des
difficultés a parfois comprendre les
codes des uns et des autres on va
essayer de parler de ça ensemble
aujourd'hui quand on passe d'une
génération on parle d'un groupe qui a
grandi qui a été modelée par la même
musique par le même environnement
socio-économique et donc un groupe une
génération est un groupe qui a une
vision du monde qui est forcément
différente de la vision de ses parents
edit sera forcément différente de la
vision de ses enfants quelques mémoires
de la bible
heures on est né juste après la guerre
nous ceux qui sont nés avant 60 et donc
nos parents nous ont appris à pas jeter
a pas jeté le pain à éteindre les
lumières quand on sort d'une pièce ce
que nos enfants ont du mal à comprendre
et c'est important de leur expliquer
pourquoi on a cette attitude là on a une
génération qui a appris à attendre aussi
parce que pour aller au bord de la mer
il fallait prendre la nationale 7 et
c'était long et puis peut-être certains
d'entre vous s'en souviennent à peine
arrivé au bord de la mer il fallait
attendre trois heures encore avant de se
baigner montgrillet sur la plage parce
qu'on nous avait dit que si on se
baignait trois heures après l avoir
déjeuné et bien on risquait
l'hydrocution maintenant on est revenus
là dessus par contre s'est inquiété
personne que on était en train de
griller au soleil parce qu'il n'y avait
pas de prévention par rapport au risque
de mélanome
à cette époque là bref les codes ce
n'étaient pas les mêmes
et il va falloir qu'on les partage
d'autant plus qu' on avait un travail
on avait eu un travail et on pensait le
garder toute notre vie et d'ailleurs on
l'a gardé toute notre vie ça fait plus
de trente ans que je suis dans le même
hôpital
ce qui n'est certainement pas le code
des générations actuelles
donc ça c'était avant en 2019 les codes
ne sont plus les mêmes
et bien entendu quand on parle de
malentendu entre les générations on a
l'impression que c'est l'histoire qui se
répète et que ça a toujours existé et
que ça existe depuis l'origine de
l'humanité puisque si on convoque
aristote si on convoque socrates
eh bien ils ont tous dit à un moment
donné c'est bizarre la jeunesse mal
élevé semble se moquer d'autoriser donc
pourquoi faire un télex finalement sur
un sujet qui est aussi habituel et
d'ailleurs on pourrait même rajouter que
l'entrée dans la vie adulte et on l'a
tous vécu c'est un moment donné
l'obligation de se déconnecter du
système familial d'ailleurs
étymologiquement éduquer ex du quéré
conduire au dehors donc finalement
pourquoi faire une conférence sur ce
sujet là maintenant finalement on
pourrait le dire
quoi de neuf docteur dans cette histoire
puisque depuis la nuit des temps les
générations ne communique pas forcément
de la même façon alors il n'y a pas que
moi qui ait ce discours là et vous avez
sans doute lu ce petit livre remarquable
de michel serres philosophe qui dit
attention il ya un être nouveau qui a
paru dans un espace de temps qui est
très réduit depuis les années 70
communique pas la même façon il n'a pas
la même perception du monde que les
autres et surtout le fil rouge de michel
serres c'est de dire dans la
transmission de l'information qui est
notre pain quotidien en tant que parent
en tant qu'enseignant en tant que
médecin en tant que manager c'est de
dire que dans la transmission de
l'information dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
il ya eu trois révolutions il ya très
longtemps l'écriture puis l'imprimerie
et en 95 internet et que l'arrivée
d'internet a conduit un tournant à 180
degrés dans l'éducation dans la
pédagogie dans le soin dans le
management
parce que jusqu'à internet la
transmission était descendante et
verticale
si mon patron me le dis si mes parents
me le disent c'est que c'est vrai et
j'ai pas les moyens d'aller vérifier si
c'est vrai ou si c'est pas vrai et avec
internet on s'est mis à horizontale is
et la transmission de l'information
donc ce code là qui a changé eh bien il
n'a pas changé depuis plus de 300 ans
était le même et maintenant on a un
nouveau code totalement différent il va
falloir faire avec
alors finalement est ce que vous êtes
des mutants est ce que les jeunes
adultes sont des mutants on pourrait se
poser la question en fait
restez connectés maintenant avec des
générations qui sont si différentes de
nous peut ressembler un véritable défi
c'est un challenge un challenge assez
incroyable on va voir ce défi il se
passe bien si on arrive à mieux se
comprendre si on arrive à mieux
décrypter les codes des uns et les
autres et combien d'adolescents sont
contents quand je leur explique pourquoi
leurs parents fonctionne comme ça avec
eux alors choisissez votre camp mais
pour la plupart d'entre vous vous êtes y
war z
il ya peut-être quelques hics au milieu
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ces limites elles sont pas tranchées le
soin intriqués et qu'on peut très bien
sentir baby boomer si on est né en 62 ou
l' inverse
mais néanmoins on va voir que à chaque
génération il ya des codes qui sont
particuliers des codes qu'on doit
vraiment comprendre pour pouvoir
s'ajuster dans la relation avec nos
collaborateurs avec nos parents ou avec
nos enfants
les codes spécifiques des baby boomers
je pense que on les connaît
on a grandi on a eu la chance de grandir
dans une période qui était facile qui
était optimiste la prière immédiat
c'étaient les trente glorieuses qui ont
duré jusqu'à aux chocs pétroliers
c'étaient les 4p propre spirit et
progrès paix et plein emploi donc nos
parents nous ont fait grandir dans un
monde en nous disant mais ça va bien se
passer pour vous vous avez de la chance
et du coup on a fabriqué une génération
de baby boomer assez paisible assez
optimiste
une génération qui respecte forcément
l'autorité quand elle vient d'en haut
qui est très attaché à ses valeurs
très attaché aux valeurs familiales et
aux valeurs de l'entreprise avec un
espèce d'amour du maillot qui est assez
particulier et qu'on retrouve plus
souvent maintenant notre musique
stelrock et puis le disco et puis on a
vendu à votre génération et j'étais dans
les boîtes de nuit à ce moment là pour
dire vous êtes bronn tout bios life
était pas étonnant que votre génération
aussi se soient emparés aussi du disco
et que dans les soirées les générations
y est déjà rassurant z on entend du
disco qui représente cette période qui
était assez facile donc nos codes à nous
c'était de voir c'est comme ça et pas
autrement nous disait ton donc tu vas le
faire et en plus tu n'as pas de plaindre
car a pas de guerre en europe en tout
cas tu auras un job tu vas pouvoir le
garder
donc on a ce code là et même moi qui
étais un enfant hyperactif qui a eu du
mal un peu à l'école à cause et
d'hyperactivité
quand j'étais petit dans ce monde qui
était à l'époque serein et solide la
société était solide avec des bases et
bien moi qui étais hyper actif
j'étais contenu et j'ai pas si certains
s'en souviennent
mais j'avais un harnais et une laisse et
nos parents nous promener en laisse et
ça choquait personne ce qui serait
certainement maintenant oui comment les
codes peuvent se transformer après nous
sont arrivées la génération x que couple
en a appelé x parce qu'il ya bien
sordide avait une génération qui était
un peu plus en difficulté qui allait
arriver après c'est énorme bloc de baby
boomer après hier
et on voyait arriver déjà allez y avec
la musique en perfusion et n'aimant pas
trop les réunions et changeant
totalement de style et une génération
qui allait être un peu coincé l'appeler
la génération x
c'est la génération du baby boom est
c'est à dire qu'il ya eu une période un
peu plus compliqué on l'a dit à cause du
choc pétrolier et pour eux ils sont
battus ils sont battus pour garder leur
valeur ils les ont gardées avec talent
avec brio mais néanmoins ils ont compris
que la vie était moins facile que la vie
n'était pas un long fleuve tranquille
au niveau affectif au niveau
professionnel et qu'il fallait se battre
pour garder ces valeurs là et que pour
réussir il fallait s'accrocher à son
poste
c'est sûr que j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'en ai plein dans mes collaborateurs à
l'hôpital autour de moi ils sont loyaux
ils sont respectueux il commence à
douter un peu des valeurs de
l'institution
c'est plus compliqué sont pas toujours
très bon communicant et une fois encore
ils sont coincés entre deux grosses
génération leur musique c'était le punk
et le new wave leur code
à voir ce que j'ai je suis pas sûr de le
garder donc il faut que je marque boute
sur mon post sur mon statut social car
je sais maintenant que je risque de le
perdre tant elle quitté l'optimisme des
baby boomers
et puis ensuite des arrivées ensuite
sont arrivés de nouvelle génération
initié par la génération y est c'est de
nouvelle génération elles ont en commun
un truc fondamental c'est que les
donneurs de valeurs ne sont plus les
mêmes
nous c'était l'armée la religion les
parents les managers les profs
c'était donc descendants maintenant lui
donnèrent de valeur sont horizontaux et
c'est tellement fort que pour la
première fois au monde
deux générations les y est les aides
apprennent des choses alors pas ça
n'existait pas amap et à mon époque
c'est à dire que jamais mes parents
m'ont dit est ce que tu peux m'aider à
ça alors que nous tous ici
s'il ya quelques baby boomer et quelques
hics on a tous demandé un jour à vous ou
y et oz est ce que tu pourrais pas
d'installer une application on va l'air
malin quand l'application qu'on leur
demande d'installer c'est justement pour
bloquer la confidentialité sur sur leurs
réseaux sociaux bref on a tous demandé
ça donc il faut accepter aussi que en
tant que manager en tant que chef de
service à l'hôpital
en tant que parents parfois on s'est
moins bien faire et on peut pas
s'arc-bouter sur des points
mission du siècle dernier voire du
millénaire dernier puisque c'était un
autre millénaire vos codes les y va vous
les à prendre vos codes c'est vivre
c'est prendre du plaisir c'est avoir un
bon équilibre entre la vie
professionnelle et la vie privée
il est hors de question que ma vie
privée soit entachée par la vie
professionnelle est fort différent des
deux générations d'avant et on verra que
les codes des aides ont aussi changé et
que s'éloigne un peu des y est sont dans
le partage pour des raisons dont on va
parler juste après alors pourquoi
pourquoi on en est arrivé là
pourquoi il ya eu ce tournant à 180
degrés et une fois encore un tournant
qu'on ne reverra pas pendant très très
longtemps
donc c'est l'enjeu de communication
comme celle ci était extrêmement
important il ya des raisons éducative et
je bats ma coulpe
parce que comme tous les baby boomer je
pense qu'on a fait des erreurs avec nos
enfants on a fait des erreurs parce
qu'on a voulu absolument avoir des
enfants rois qu'on assure investir
pourquoi des enfants rois
parce que d'abord on les a choisis on a
vécu nous ce qui n'existera plus la
parenthèse enchantée s'est ouverte avec
la pilule et qui s'est refermée que le
sida donc on a vécu des années de
libération sexuelle
vous pouvez choisir la mare un enfant ou
pas en avoir on en a eu moins donc plus
de pression sur chaque enfant et
bichette des enfants et bien on les a
élevés on voulait pas qu'ils souffrent
on voulait qu'il soit plus heureux que
peut-être on pensait pas la variété en
tout cas dans la communication avec nos
parents on a on leur a offert plein de
choses on les a beaucoup photographié
on les a rendus narcissique à cause de
du numérique
et d'ailleurs c'est un conseil que je
donnerais à mes petits enfants et à mes
enfants et petits-enfants c'est de leur
dire avant de prendre en photo ton fils
au ta fille faut pas en faire mille
comme on l'a fait avec nos enfants
poser la question est ce que tu
m'autorise à oui donc mon image a une
certaine valeur
donc je vais parler la galvauder sur les
réseaux sociaux comme l'ont fait mes
grands frères ou comme l'ont fait mes
parents donc on les a rendus narcissique
on leur a pas assez dit non on les a pas
assez critiqué bilan des courses quand
il arrive dans l'entreprise ou quand ils
arrivent face aux difficultés
ils sont plus en difficulté justement
pour affronter ces problèmes là et
illzach
il accepte difficilement la critique on
vous assure protéger
départ en hélicoptère c'est à dire que
même si on imagine que nos enfants
soient autonomes
on est tellement inquiet de ce qui se
passe dans le monde que quand ils
partent on leur dit tu m'envoies un sms
tu me dis dès que tu arrives tu me dis
chez qui tu vas et l'autre il nous
réécrire t'inquiète je gère en fait il
gère rien du tout on est d'accord mais
au moins il sait qu'il a les lits
coquelles à l'hélico il est un peu
pénible mais il est pratique aussi
combien de mamans me disent mais à 20
ans quand je l'entends de téléphoner
pour me demander où j'ai rangé son sweat
à capuche ou et son certificat de
scolarité
c'est à dire que la génération y a
appris à appeler les ics optèrent à tout
moment qui vient se poser dans la cour
de l'école
quand il ya un problème pour aller voir
les preuves bref c'est par hélicoptère
n'ont pas permis aux enfants d'atteindre
aussi rapidement l'indépendance
l'autonomie et surtout le dernier point
est fondamental et depuis que j'ai
compris ça et que je le mets en pratique
à l'hôpital par exemple eh bien ils
attendent un retour vous attendez un
retour positif parce que vos parents
vous ont tellement dit que c'était super
que si on vous dit pas que c'est bien on
pensait que c'est mal alors que moi
quand j'étais à l'hôpital et que je
faisais un geste compliqué une ponction
lombaire et que mon patron me disait pas
c'est mal ça veut dire que c'était bien
donc il faut inverser aussi notre
fonctionnement à partir du moment où on
a compris comment les uns et les autres
fonctionnel et puis la société on est
passé d'un d'un passé simple on l'a vu à
un futur incertain donc le présent est
compliqué pas étonnant que les
génération y et z et envie de profiter
de la vie se soit autoproclamé you do
you only ones
c'est ça la vie je commence par le
dessert il mon épanouissement personnel
n'est pas négociable
et là on peut commencer à discuter avec
mon patron avec mon chef de service avec
mes parents et puis arrive les aides les
aides et bien scellé y qu'ils ont ouvert
la porte mais les aides sont un peu
différents ils ont leurs icônes
ils ont leurs codes le partage la
solidarité la justice est assez
intéressant ce qui est assez nouveau et
ils descendent directement des x et d y
est là il ya un premier changement parce
que les aide beaucoup de z qui
descendent des y ne vont pas avoir à
apprendre des choses à leurs parents les
parents vont récupérer leur légitimité
qu'ils avaient perdu un moment donné
et donc il ya quelque chose qui va
bouger dans le bon sens il aspire à la
sécurité à la stabilité parce que ils
ont trop connu d'attentât de guerre de
choses violentes et puis même tirait pas
forcément plus qu'avant ils sont sûrs
père informé il se passe quelque chose à
l'autre bout du monde et l'ont
immédiatement sur leurs smartphones
il cherche stabilité ils sont connectés
souvent à plusieurs raisons à la fois il
utilise beaucoup la dérision et l'humour
parce que les réseaux sociaux lors leur
ont appris à encaisser la dérision à
encaisser l'autodérision a encaissé la
critique
ils seront beaucoup plus à l'aise avec
les critiques que l'était la génération
y
son livre rien ne leur appartient tous
emprunté le vélo la voiture le coworking
covoiturage il voyage comme déjà les
grecs le faisaient ils vont bouger c'est
la génération easyjet
et puis sont très matures très informé
lucide sur ce qui se passe dans le monde
optimiste bien plus que les grecs parce
que ils savent qu'ils vont trouver du
boulot dans les pays émergents donc leur
vie est plus sereine leur vie est plus
tranquille mais ils sont quand même
émotif les américains l'appellent les
émaux boomer et mots parce que souvent
eh bien ils ont les larmes aux yeux à 12
13 ans quand les profs leur dire quelque
chose
la critique ils la prennent ils
l'acceptent mais ça les touche les
boumeurs parce qu'ils sont comme les
baby boomers
ils reprennent des valeurs des baby
boomer de rigueur on les appelle
maintenant pour pas faire trop fin de
siècle la génération c pour les quatre
ses collaborations communication
connexions et créativité cette
créativité qui était un obstacle pour
nous deux ma bible murray x et qui est
une nécessité absolue pour la génération
y la génération z
alors il se démarque de leurs aînés ils
cherchent un un retour positif avec des
adultes ils ont une bien meilleure
lecture des adultes ils veulent
cohabitation pacifique avec les adultes
ils veulent que ça se passe bien ils
savent très bien ce qu'ils veulent ils
finissent par l'obtenir mais par la
périphérie ils vont nous demander les
choses à papa à maman pour obtenir au
bout du compte qui souhaitent
bref ils sont plus sensibles aux
arguments de l'adulte à condition que
l'adulte et su acquérir sa légitimité et
c'est ça qui est très important et c'est
peut-être le plus important c'est que la
légitimité des baby boomer et dx qui
était innée maintenant il faut aller la
chercher
il faut aller l'acquérir et pour
l'acquérir il faut tenir compte des
codes dont on vient de parler pour
l'acquérir
il faut avoir une un discours
authentique supporte pas la langue de
bois
juste un discours argumenté ferme donc
rassurant pour cette population qui a
besoin qu'on la rassure et humble donc
bienveillant ils ont un rapport
décomplexé à l'erreur ils sont plantés
sur les sur les jeux vidéo il n'accepte
pas que leur manager que leurs parents
que leur médecin ne reconnaissent pas
ses propres erreurs et là on a un
discours qui peut fonctionner termine
avec sept rangs la parole à michel
serres qui dit attention la génération z
hyper connectés horizontale créative
elle est en train d'y nervis toute la
société
attention notre monde est en train de
glisser tranquillement vers le leur il
faut en tenir compte alors en tirent
contre c'est quoi pour les accompagner
est ce que c'est une mission impossible
non c'est pas une mission impossible à
condition qu'on comprenne leur code
à condition qu'on ait compris comment il
fonctionnait à condition qu'on soit à
leur écoute qu'on les respecte
j'avais écrit un petit article sur sa
sueur il faut ajuster le rapport
hiérarchique en tenant compte de tous
ces éléments premiers éléments il vit
dans le présent
ils veulent des solutions rapides des
résultats visibles deuxième élément il
préfère comprendre plutôt 400 da
costières d'apprendre puisque j'ai tout
sur internet bien mieux fait que ce
cours vous pouvez me proposer il préfère
comprendre plutôt qu'à prendre il faut
convaincre plutôt que contraindre et 3e
code qui est aussi très important comme
ils savent plus de choses que leurs
parents il faut qu'on accepte
nous les parents vous les médecins les
managers les enseignants de se laisser
enseigner et accepté de leur demander
des explications
bref steve jobs dit la même chose à quoi
ça servirait d'embaucher des gens
intelligents
si on leur dit ce qu'il faut faire alors
qu'on attend d'eux qu'ils nous
expliquent ce qu'il faut faire et puis
même à la maison
on peut aussi parfois avoir envie de
dire à son fils il est temps qu'on parle
de sexe ils pourraient nous répondre
avec l'humour et l'autodérision
qu'est ce que tu veux savoir donc c'est
une génération qui est bien plus
informés qu'on imagine et puis néanmoins
même si assez justement ils ont quand
même la même question qui pose à tous
les parents qui posent aux chefs
d'entreprise qui posent aux directeurs
d'école au chef de l'état
rassurez-nous avec tout ce qu'on entend
dans le monde
rassurez nous dit nous est ce qu'il ya
un pilote dans l'avion est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui dirige ce cette école ce
pays
cette famille et je laisse la parole
finale à oscar wilde qui dit en parlant
des nouvelles générations
la nouvelle génération est épouvantable
j'aimerais tellement en faire partie je
vous remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]